democrats tearing into each other after
some tough election losses
centrist congressman tim ryan calling
out the far left saying quote
our brand is not good we have 70 million
people who either hate us or afraid of
us or believe
there is this vast spread of socialism
in our party
it is why we lost so many seats in the
house or some
seats were a lot closer than we wanted
and moderate senator joe manchin says he
won't support radical ideas if democrats
take over the senate
i truly believe that chuck schumer can
work with
mitch mcconnell i believe that in my
heart and soul that we can look at
things we can
i've taken off the table forget about
packing the courts forget about the
filibuster forget about blowing things
up they've been using that as a scare
tactic
that's not going to happen but nancy
pelosi still
appeasing the progressives she refused
to denounce socialism after fox news
reached
out to her office several times for
comment greg how could she not
respond to a simple fox news request
she's not gonna take the bait jesse
she's way too smart for that
look here's the my here's my problem
i've been on this planet i'm about in my
mid-30s yes
i've never seen the party not move left
like every time every time there's this
discussion
it's not like it ever there's never ever
a correction
i mean i remember that bill clinton was
supposed to be a correction and then i
remember that
obama no everything always moves left
and the reason why is because that's
what the media wants the media
is the third party in this it's not just
the two it's not just the left and the
far left of the democrats
the media is far far left i've never
seen it a single
critical piece about in the mainstream
media about aoc
or anybody from the squad i've never
seen it you could
literally marry your brother on fifth
avenue
and the time the new york times would
champion your family values
i'm serious like that whole story it's
like that just show it's like
it there's no such thing as moderate of
it moving back to the center never does
one they said that you know biden would
be elected and
and the republicans would start working
with the democrats and everything would
go back to normal
do you see that happening not at the
moment they seem locked into
being obstructionists i don't know i
don't get it i don't understand why
they're going off on this business
about fraud instead of saying you know
what joe biden you won
let's work together that i think would
be healthy for the cause do you think
mcconnell
and chuck schumer are going to
break bread and make sure everything's
bipartisan
because that was the promise that joe
biden delivered no no no but i think
that that would happen i mean this is
our history by the way this has happened
in the past republicans and democrats
used to be able to work together i think
we're in a really polarized place
it's not great i will say this though it
seems to me that democrats really are
a big tent party and i'm not sure you're
picking up on that they
have to compromise in order to keep
their caucus together in a very big way
and we've seen this in the recent past
remember among democrats obamacare was a
compromise
the economic stimulus plan that helped
the auto industry recover
after the recession that was a
conference among
democrats and politically aoc and
bernie really in this past election
guess what they compromised in terms of
supporting
joe biden they did not stand in the way
and
make a big fuss and tell people don't on
the left oh he's not your guy he's not
sufficiently
radical so don't vote for him they
didn't do that they didn't do that at
all i think
she was running for president i think
aoc and the socialists think they have
more juice katie than they actually have
because she endorsed bernie
ernie flamed out clyburn he endorsed
joe biden and he got the nomination yeah
but the issue here is that
democrats in order to keep the middle of
the country continue to say
that socialism or communism aren't big
parts of their party
they're absolutely massive parts of
their party you have bernie sanders
do you want to talk about bernie sanders
like humans we don't have all day so i
won't go down there
yeah communism look it up bernie sanders
thinks that cuban communism the health
care system in america is a good
is what we should emulate in the united
states in terms of medicare for all
and government-run healthcare but we
don't have time to go through bernie
sanders
record when it comes to i don't know
honeymooting in the ussr when it was
still a communist country
but we'll move on to what i was going to
say which is
democrats continue to try and alienate
this leftist part of their their
their party that is very aggressive
while also keeping them close because
they know they have to work with them
bernie sanders ran for president twice
was very successful almost beat hillary
clinton
you have aoc on the cover of magazines
with nancy pelosi
and look they can't denounce socialists
now because kamala harris
is the vice president elect allegedly
according to
fox news calling it and and um you know
her whole platform is socialism she's a
green new deal
she said she wants to get rid of private
insurance and obamacare by the way was
not a
compromise it was a first step to
medicare for all in government-run
health insurance which we're seeing
joe biden talk about just today when he
gave that speech earlier
you can see the fault lines forming in
the party and you're here for it
i cannot wait for all of it i've sort of
been thought that this would happen like
since 2015
when bernie sanders was on the scene i'm
like okay here it is it's coming over
the wall but then they held it together
because of they were against trump
that was a unifying force for them and
now they don't necessarily have that and
it's all playing out in the open which
is a lot of fun
um i also think though that you know
senator manchin
he does speak as a moderate but a lot of
his votes
are to what greg's point was is that it
there left
a lot of them voted against tax cuts
voted for impeachment
voted against amy coney barrett voted
against the coveted relief deals and so
you have this situation where you have
something like joe manchin suggest
that um it's a republican scare tactic
to bring up court packing for example
but republicans didn't say that first
chuck schumer did
so you'll see this also in georgia um so
i know we're talking about a lot about
georgia but we should because that's
where all the marbles that's that it was
really for all the marbles
so he says things to one audience
and then another to somebody else so he
said it was important
that funding for police departments
should absolutely be on the line
okay he said that but he was running ads
in rural georgia
saying that he stands with the police
and he did the same things on guns he
went on msnbc
saying one thing ran ads saying another
so it's just you know
be aware typical democrat